all right to know john tapper is to love
john taffer isn't it um and and i'm
biased in this world because the guy is
a gruff exterior and i don't want to
embarrass him but he's as soft as a mush
and we'll give you the shirt off his
back especially for the restaurant
industry and he's proven it again and
again i'm sorry john i had to just say
that he joins us right now um and john
you're coming to your fellow restaurant
brethren's rescue again and that they
need some help now they're kicking
around relief for restaurants bars cafes
etc uh i don't know how far it goes a
lot of people hearing this are saying do
they need it you say they do
of course we need it now we're getting
it from all sides not only can't we get
employees to facilitate the business
that we did have before the latest
variant but our food prices are off the
charts neil i mean when you get hit from
a labor side a product cost side and a
revenue side we're getting assaulted
from all sides and there is a fatigue
factor too neil let's face it we've been
through heck these past two years so
we're fighting for our lives and a
little bit of relief to get us over this
hump now is really required it worked
last time it kept this going and it'll
work this time too
you know they are disproportionately
affected by these on-again off-again
vaccine mandates and then mask mandates
and then customers who say the hell with
the mandates i'm just not coming
uh so their business can be like a
geiger counter how are they dealing with
that
well it's difficult neil but you know
something that's really not mentioned
much is a restaurant typically costs
three times more to build than a retail
store so we're dealing with the debt of
building the restaurant as well as the
additional labor cost if we can get it
and the lack of revenues you know the
numbers don't work and there's no way we
can make it work we can't charge 24 for
a hamburger the consumer is going to
resist so our margins keep getting cut
and cut and cut the fact of the matter
is it's an external environment that's
caused this now restaurant operators
have stepped up we've sanitized the
restaurants we've staffed our people
safely we've created the kind of
environments that are conducive to
healthy dining and healthy workspace
we've done everything asked of us but
we're still getting squished by this
environment
you know john this might shock you but i
love to eat and i love to eat out and
almost every restaurant i go to and it's
not a an insult uh they have a devil all
the time getting good help and so you
wait you know what you were
for food and all and i can deal with
that because i certainly understand what
they're going through but it's a problem
everywhere isn't it
oh it's a huge problem i've refrained it
as a sign in front of his restaurant
that says service is going to take a
little longer but please be nice to the
people who chose to show up today
and it's it's sort of a shame neil
because the people that show up are the
ones that are in a pressure cooker
because of the ones that haven't shown
up but you know the food thing is
interesting you know i know you're a
steak guy if i get a steak a certain
size and a certain thickness and now i
can't get that size the other stake is
too small on a plate it doesn't look
right it's too big
these are not small matters ketchup for
example comes in a little packet you
can't get the packets so now i have to
put the ketchup in a ramekin i don't
have the ramekin i can't get the ramekin
so now i finally find a way to get the
ramekin but neil the ramekin then
doesn't fit on the plate so i mean these
are nightmares for us as operators just
to try to get out a nice looking healthy
and delicious plate of food is a huge
challenge for us now every day
yeah i want the steaks looking like they
had fred flintstone those type of things
you know but i know how do you see it
going in the months ahead how do you you
see this calming down government health
no government out there what do you see
well you know the consumers really
stepped up a few months ago many
restaurants were up 25
from pre-pandemic levels neil so the
revenues were there we were seeing light
at the end of the tunnel then of course
this variant came and took our revenues
away but the food prices and the
inflationary impact on the industry has
been huge as well particularly when you
start to add additional labor costs to
it you know the numbers just don't work
if you look at a restaurant about 33 is
food cost about 30 percent is labor cost
about 20 percent is beverage because
when you put it all together just the
prime costs can run sixty percent before
you pay your rent utilities
it's it's too tight of the margins to
make it work we really need this relief
package we shall see john
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else